Destinee - seems to be filling in the
gaps of what the original was missing
after a slow drip of details we finally
have more information including a
long-awaited look at gameplay we'll have
more to come including hands-on
impressions from the destiny to events
so make sure to subscribe so you don't
miss any more updates for now whether
you're new to destiny or a veteran
guardian these are the nine things you
need to know to prepare for the
September release instead of the first
games primary secondary and heavy weapon
classes destiny - changes it up a bit
the three slots will be energy kinetic
and power power weapons include things
like fusion and sniper rifles in the
newly revealed grenade launchers while
the kinetic and energy slots will allow
for some overlap we also got to see two
new weapon types the chain gun and the
grenade launcher we've seen some new
super abilities in action for the
existing destiny classes warlocks get a
sword based move called the dawn blade
that can be used to attack enemies from
above and it shoots fire Titans get
Sentinel which allows you to summon a
shield and use it Captain America style
and finally the arc Strider super which
is for hunters let's use summon a staff
that you can swing around and slam
enemies with
[Music]
in destiny one raids and nightfall
strikes which were the hardest and most
rewarding activities in the game didn't
have matchmaking that meant having to
put in a lot of work to get a group
together and if you didn't have enough
people with you to play you were out of
luck to fix that destiny to is
introducing official clan support to
help you coordinate things in game
that's a godsend for those of us with
several text threads dedicated to
organizing grades the game will also
feature a kind of matchmaking called
guided games where you can search for
clans who need another person to play
with and choose who you want to join
it's a more focused form of matchmaking
that's incredibly exciting if you play
solo pretty often since you'll have more
control over who you're playing with and
can hopefully avoid a bad time
[Music]
there will be four new worlds to explore
in destiny - Titan IO Nexus and Earth's
European dead zone there will still be
patrols in destiny - but that's not all
you'll be doing in these new areas
unlike the original there will be a
greater emphasis on exploration we saw
towns and NPCs who give quests and one
map is twice the size of any of the
areas from destiny one part of the more
open worlds in destiny - are more robust
side quests known as adventures these
can involve hunting down treasure
featuring bonafide Maps and discovering
lost sectors home to a boss that holds
the treasure chests key
it sounds simple but destiny - lets you
launch activities from the planet or
world you're on without going to orbit
first just open the map pick where you
want to go and get there faster destiny
choose crucible will be for view for
only that means some game types from the
first destiny will either change or
disappear entirely
and multiplayer will shift to focus on
game modes for smaller teams one of the
new modes is called countdown but we
don't know much about it yet but our own
Erik Kay has been checking out the
crucible so keep your eyes up Guardian
for some more gameplay
[Music]
unlike the original destiny - will be
available on PC in addition to ps4 and
Xbox one you'll be able to get it
exclusively through blizzards battlenet
platform and use battlenet built-in
friends lists and chat with destiny -
the PC version will also offer 4k
support and uncap frame rates if you
played the first destiny sry power
possessions and ever verse related items
and currency won't carry over into
destiny - however your character's
appearance will transfer so there's that
[Music]
Destinee - will launch on September 8th
and we'll have ps4 exclusive content for
a time it'll have a season pass called
the expansion pass that includes new
story missions co-op activities
multiplayer and new weapons armor and
gear there's also an open beta before
launch but if you preorder the game you
can play the beta early and with that
you're armed with the key details about
destiny - stay tuned for even more
destiny to news and gameplay leading up
to September 8th including an entire
playthrough of the first new strike
inverted spire
[Music]
you